it's been a while since anyone prayed in
this mosque in northern Jakarta the sea
has long since claimed it it makes Irfan
palanga and said every time he sees the
building the sinking of the city is
increasing in past few few years and it
touched me a lot because you can imagine
people say their prayers years before
and they cannot do it anymore the
Indonesian capital of Jakarta is home to
over 30 million people it's one of the
most densely populated cities in the
world and it has a problem the threat
isn't obvious here in the heart of the
city but it's severe in the north's home
too many fishing communities there's no
ignoring the rising sea waters this
break wall was built in 2002 in the
morrible district as protection against
flooding the seawall is continuously
being reinforced and raised but that
doesn't help after a spell of heavy
rainfall the water begins pouring over
again Jakarta is sinking when the ground
water is being extracted very much and
we lost our water catchment the the
surface and the soil is become sinking
we have water extraction and then came
along by merchants in these 20 years the
the climate change impact is doubling
the affordability of the city because
it's already below water naturally
rising sea levels and sinking soil the
city needs more long-term solutions
belongin used to be an environmental
activist to campaign for the rights of
fishermen nowadays he advises the gap
of Jakarta and as part of a team working
to stop the city from disappearing into
the ground he is well aware that
anything he plans will have an impact on
fishing there are some 22,000 fishermen
in Jakarta
these people harvest green mussels from
the bay a local speciality they're
cooked right on the beach for years ago
the city authorities began building a
chain of artificial islands off the
northern coast to slow down land
subsidence it set a serious impact on
that catches how many killers do you
catch a day about 50 kilos and what
about before the islands were built back
then we caught about 200 kilos now a new
pot is planned along with a break wall
that's actually in the sea 50 meters
offshore the fishermen are worried they
soon won't be able to catch anything at
all they've learned to live with regular
flooding but the new coastal wall would
mean the end of their livelihoods you
want to know whether the coastal wall
will disturb our access to the sea I say
that even if it has benefits for the
community the development plan has to be
discussed with the affected community
pool ngang wants the fishermen to be
part of the decision-making
the covered market where they sell their
catch is nearby here too it's impossible
to overlook the city's plight the market
was only built five years ago but huge
cracks are already showing buildings in
some parts of Jakarta are sinking into
the ground at a rate of up to 25
centimeters a year this major fountain
in the heart of Jakarta belies the fact
that clean water isn't desperately short
supply half the Capitals population
draws its water from illegal wells and
vast amounts of groundwater are used by
the new high-rises springing up across
town that needs more regulations ESPA
longan to develop a more water
absorption facilities to strengthen
their waste management facilities and
also to finalize where they pilot
violating their water licensing the city
is searching for ways to conserve the
precious resource preventing groundwater
levels from further declining is
essential otherwise Jakarta will sink
even faster and flooding will pose an
even bigger threat wasteth another
problem in the monsoon season especially
trash clocks up rivers and canals so
waterways can't drain into the sea these
days an army of about 12,000 trash
collectors work around the clock
battling the garbage emergency a number
of compounds or settlements have already
been evacuated and torn down in the name
of flood protection the company of trunk
oil was slated for demolition in 2015
the huts we're directly on the river and
inhabitants were supposed to be evicted
then they took matters into their own
hands they've torn down
parts of their homes themselves removing
sections on the water's edge three years
ago we cut our house and before we some
cleaning reefer activities and before we
plant some vegetables or flour and
anything here this yeah not really
perfect the result is a thriving
peaceful community and residents who
take pride and keeping the neighborhood
trash free and there's now a Riverside
walkway that's a comfortable distance
from the water the community also has
the support of a team of architects who
developed a sustainable model home for
tone call it's made of stone and wood
rather than plastic and sheet metal
seven families live here this is small
house like pigeon house among them are
Google Maura met his wife and their two
children cooler than before and I have
window this is important for me because
in the past I don't have window the
architects are pinning their hopes on
sustainable living solutions and social
change well I'm not saying the physical
result is not important but I think the
social process that comes with it is the
most important social responsibility
sustainable water management the people
of Tom Cole have shown what's possible
the community has become a model of
clean and green living now the
neighborhood enjoys state support even
palanga in hopes the authorities are
starting to understand that when it
comes to ensuring the city's survival
the urban poor in north and Jakarta are
part of the solution not the problem